would you have another baby oh you
no thank you I mean sometimes it's like
no I waited a long time yeah okay okay
there we have it Heidi klum's not
opposed to expanding her family in her
50s someone always needs to be driven
somewhere someone always has a problem
then there's school work then there's a
tutor that is like it's just my house is
crazy yeah the model has a full house
with her four kiddos already Laney Henry
Johann and Lou even with heels they're
like taller than me it's just crazy all
the way around life is crazy you know
you give birth to four kids and then all
of a sudden they have outgrown you that
said the soon-to-be 50 year old
supermodel Jennifer Hudson she'd be down
for one more but she did have a think
about it a little bit would you have
another baby oh you
no thank you I mean sometimes it's like
me it depends what day it is sometimes
I'm here sometimes here you know yeah
maybe not I mean it's a lot I've done it
four times
you're so funny I breastfed eight months
each time and then and then I was
pregnant again
three times in a row again I have an 18
a 17 a 16 and a 13 so I was like you
know when I walk in the house you know I
put my bag down and like I'm already
running down the hallway Mommy
and they're like on me and then we're in
the kitchen sitting around the table I
mean it's Mayhem they are loud and this
and that and I mean I think every night
something gets spilled with four kids
the milk is going the juice is going and
you know yeah but I love it I love it
that's how I always wanted it I always
wanted
um you know a house full of life and
laughter Heidi's House first started
filling up when Lenny was born in 2004.
her dad is Italian businessman Flavio
briatore while her one-time stepdad seal
is the father to her siblings Henry
Johann and Lou Hattie and the singer
split in 2012 after seven years of
marriage and a lot of moms out there
want to know the secret to co-parenting
especially when you're one place in
their dad's somewhere else you know I
mean it works it works it works you make
it work you make it like everything a
new addition would be Heidi's first kid
with her current husband musician Tom
Cowlitz he's 16 years younger than the
supermodel I have a man in my life who I
love very much it's just all around it's
a lot of fun
[Music]